Dans les trois vidéos précédentes on a étudié la morale d'un point de vue descriptif et prédictifs d'une certaine manière on étudiait la morale naturelle
ou du moins la morale sélectionnée par la sélection naturelle
mais on a aussi vu que cette morale était loin d'être clairement la bonne morale on a vu notamment qu'elle nous poussait à l'hooliganisme
politique et donc à la confrontation entre groupes rivaux et je ne vous parle pas du fait que les moral de nos ancêtres à coups
de torture d'esclavagé de lutte des classes sont loin de faire consensus
aujourd'hui bref on a étudié ce que la morale et est du coup maintenant vous devriez avoir envie de savoir ce que la morale
devrait être eh bien c'est ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui on va étudier la morale dit prescriptive qu'on appelle aussi
normative et pour bien en parler j'ai invité un philosophe que j'adore tivo de la chaîne de sophie
salut c'est un plaisir d'être ici pour parler de morale celle thibault allez vas-y fais nous la morale on a tendance à penser la morale
comme un ensemble de principes formulés à
l'impératif par exemple la fameuse règle d'or ne fais pas à autrui ce que tu ne voudrais pas qu'on te fasse
c'est ce qu'on appelle une approche déontologiques en ceci que la valeur morale d'une action dépendra de sa conformité à un ensemble de règles
morales et peu importe ses conséquences être moral c'est avoir des principes et s'y tenir
cette approche notamment celle du grand philosophe emmanuel kant selon quand il existe deux types d' impératifs moraux des impératifs
hypothétique et les impératifs catégoriques les impératifs hypothétique sont de forme si tu veux y alors tu dois faire x donc
l'impératif tu dois x ne vaut que comme un moyen de réaliser cette fin y or pour quand les impératifs moraux doit valoir
absolument donc ils doivent être formulée sans conditions hypothétique et s'appliquer à tous ce sont des impératifs catégoriques
ils sont de forme tu dois x tu le dois tout court
est ce tu dois vaut pour tous et dans tous les cas et quand défend ardemment l'existence d'impératif catégorique
il amène même au delà de ce que la plupart d'entre nous considèrent aurait acceptable oui quand tu es vraiment à cheval sur ces impératifs
convaincu que dire la vérité est un impératif absolu
quand soutenait que même à des assassins poursuivant un ami qui se serait réfugiée chez vous on aurait le devoir de dire la vérité
oui quand et moralement hardcore quand il a un principe ici tient et à écouter certains militants politiques ce n'est pas le seul
nombreux textes de loi ou speech politique sous entendent souvent l'existence de principes moraux qui selon eux serait
universelle où devraient être universels on parle typiquement de libertés fondamentales de droits fondamentaux de devoirs fondamentaux
et on retrouve aussi des principes déontologiques dans les fameuses trois lois de la robotique introduite par isaac asimov
loi numéro un robot ne peut porter atteinte à un être humain
ni en restant passif
permettre qu'un être humain soit exposé au danger loi numéro 2 un robot doit obéir aux ordres donnés par un être humain
sauf si de tels ordres entrent en conflit avec la première loi
loi numéro 3 un robot doit protéger son existence tant que cette protection
n'entre pas en conflit avec la première ou la deuxième loi alors ces trois lois elles peuvent paraître sens et
raisonnable sauf que les romands d'asimov montre justement que ces trois lois
échoue à saisir le comportement moral que l'on veut vraiment a signé au robot en fait construire une morale déontologique satisfaisante
c'est super galère et si vous voulez l'avis d'un expert en intelligence artificielle
je vous conseille cette superbe vidéo de computer file mais la difficulté à déterminer des impératifs catégoriques
adéquat qui font que nous serons su ce n'est pas la seule difficulté de la proche des routes aux logiques de la morale un système
biologique étant essentiellement un ensemble de règles soit une action est fait en conformité avec ces règles
et alors elle est bonne sinon elle est mauvaise or en pratique il peut arriver qu aucune action possible
pas même l'inaction ne
satisfasse toutes les règles morales et ça on n'en parle plus longuement dans la vidéo chez monsieur fille que faire quand toutes les actions possibles
sont mauvaises bah il faudra faire l'action la moins mauvaise et donc on voudrait une théorie qui permettent de
hiérarchiser les valeurs des actions d'une façon plus fine que juste bien et mal et ce à une approche purement
déontologiques en général ne le permet pas en somme un simple ensemble de règles fixant
absolument ce qui est beau ou mauvais ça ne semble pas suffisant à nous aider à agir moralement
par opposition à la proche des ontologies qu en théorie des jeux on va souvent préféré une approche utilitariste
en gros l'utilitarisme consiste à poser non pas des principes mais un
objectif à la morale et cet objectif ce sera la maximisation du bonheur général aux une situation donnée donc envisager toutes les actions possibles
associés à chacune d'elles l'effet attendu qu'elle aura sur le bonheur
des individus et choisissez celles dont l'effet attendu et le plus positif ou le moins négatif
et bien souvent quand on cherche à justifier une approche déontologique
montenvers l'utilitarisme du genre pugnière c'est bien parce que ça donne davantage d'une scène telus à
coopérer ce qui sera alors bénéfique pour tous
ce qui revient à dire que les impératifs catégoriques de forme tu dois faire x sont en fait implicitement des impératifs
hypothétique de forme si tu veut maximiser le bonheur général
alors tu dois faire x alors il y aurait beaucoup
beaucoup à dire sur les kits à rythmes et ses variantes est d'ailleurs sur scène ce forum on a parlé de comment inclure des notions
comme l'équité ou la méritocratie mais pour aujourd'hui j'aimerais insister sur un aspect très contre intuitif de l'utilitarisme qui je pense
gagnerait beaucoup à être mieux compris
la franche déontologique suppose que les devoirs moraux sont absolus donc ils s'imposent à tous dans tous les cas si dire la vérité est un
devoir absolu comme le penser quand alors il faut toujours et à tous dire la vérité peu importe les préférences de ceux qui seront touchés
par votre action un
utilitarisme au contraire s'il veut moralement bien agi hier devra s'informer et tenir compte des préférences des autres pour être toujours mieux
capables de maximiser leur bonheur donc évidemment un
utilitariste considérera qu'il a le devoir de mentir à des assassins qui cherche un ami caché chez lui mais cela va plus loin si un
utilitariste a des raisons de penser que vous
préférez ne pas entendre la vérité sur un certains sujets il aura le devoir de respecter cette préférence en vous ment temps pourvu évidemment que
ce mensonge n'est pas par ailleurs d'autres conséquences plus mauvaise et en particulier pour savoir s'il a le devoir moral de mentir
lüthi cariste aura au préalable le devoir moral de comprendre les préférences des autres et ça ça commence par
absolument arrêter les phrases du genre je comprends pas comment on peut croire que blablabla
si vous ne comprenez pas pourquoi les autres croient ce qu'il croit ce n'est pas leur faute mais bien
votre faute
et puis l'utilitarisme doit garder en tête que s'agissant du bonheur des autres ce sont les préférences des autres qui importe si l'autre est
outrée par la terminologie pains au chocolat alors l'utilitarisme aura le devoir moral de
l'éviter autant que possible en présence de l'autre même s'il est sûr et certain que la page wikipedia s'intitule bel et bien d'un chocolat
l'important n'est pas d'avoir raison l'important est de main si mise et le bonheur général en particulier
l'utilitarisme va chercher à
bannir des phrases du genre
- samouraï pas vexer moi je vois pas fait comme ça il ne faut pas faire aux autres ce qu'on ne veut pas qu'ils nous
fassent en effet cette règle d'or qui est pourtant se voient reconnus comme la règle morale la plus importante semble
fondamentalement contraire à l'utilitarisme et à bien y réfléchir sa critique semble assez profondes pour quelles raisons en traitant autrui comme il me plairait d'être
traités moi je ferai quelque chose de bien je ferai son bonheur cela semble
présupposé que autrui aura toujours les mêmes préférences que moi mais rien n'est moins sûr ne serait-il pas réellement meilleur de dire en
utilitariste ne fais pas aux autres ce que les autres ne veulent pas qu'on leur fasse
puisque ce qui importe ce n'est pas ce que vous auriez ressenti à la place d'un autre mais bel et bien ce que l'autre a
ressenti lorsqu'on lui a dit ce qu'on lui a dit et c'est pas facile car ça va contre la tendance que nous avons à
comprendre l'esprit des autres en supposant qu'il fonctionne comme le nôtre ce qui n'est pertinent que jusqu'à un certain point en sciences cognitives on parle
de théorie de l'esprit et s'il y a bien une chose qu'il faut retenir de la théorie des jeux
c'est bien l'importance de toujours se demander ce que les autres pensent et veulent notamment pour prédire l'issue des interactions humaines ou si on et
utilitariste pour maximiser le bonheur du plus grand nombre
alors tout ça ça ne veut pas dire non plus que l'utilitaire east ne va jamais forcer quelqu'un à faire quelque chose dans certains contextes
utilitariste peut avoir le devoir moral de agir de manière autoritaire
en fait l'utilitarisme tu ne donnes pas une valeur absolue à la liberté à l'égalité
ni même à la vérité d'une preuve mathématique
ou plutôt pour l'utilitaire east ce qui importe c'est ce que l'autre pense de la liberté de l'égalité ou de la preuve mathématique
si l'autre n'attache aucune importance à sa liberté peut-être parce qu'ils pensent que le libre arbitre n'est qu'une illusion et s'il
utilitariste est persuadé que l'autre finira par être heureux si on le force à écouter le podcast actions par exemple alors l'utilitarisme
n'aura aucun problème à force et l'autre à écouter le podcast
actions de façon générale 6,1 utilitariste est convaincu que en vous forçant à faire
x vous serez plus heureux que si on vous laisse la liberté de faire x ou alors ce serait pour lui
man
immoral de vous laisser la liberté de faire x et ça peut sembler choquant dit comme ça mais en fait c'est ce qu'on fait tous
quand on éduque des enfants il semble raisonnable par exemple d'obliger les enfants à aller à l'école
parce qu'on pense qu'en fin de compte ils seront plus heureux ainsi que si on les avait laissés totalement
libres d'y aller ou non de même l'utilité ariste est prêt à sacrifier la liberté de se vacciner
voire même l'exigence démocratique selon laquelle il faut qu'une majorité du peuple
veuille imposer la vaccination à tous styles et sur des bienfaits de la vaccination
et s'ils pensent que c'est bien fait
apporteront plus de bonheur que le sentiment de liberté à choisir ou à refuser de se vacciner et que la possible
frustration à devoir subir une loi antidémocratique
l'utilitarisme ne reconnaît pas la liberté l'égalité la vérité comme des valeurs absolues
sacrifier tout ça peut être moralement nécessaire s'il en résulte une maximisation du bonheur et c'est d'ailleurs en réponse un devoir moral
utilitariste que j'ai choisi de censurer les commentaires que je juge néfaste au bonheur global
ceci dit en fait la plupart des utilitaires east à cordes quand même beaucoup d'importance au respect des libertés individuelles
et c'est parce qu'il considère que arrivé à sa majorité
chacun est le meilleur juge de ce qui peut faire son bonheur on en revient ainsi à l'idée qu'il faut faire le bonheur des individus
tels que l'individu le conçoivent et non d'après l'idée personnelle que vous faites du bonheur en fait être beau et qu'il cariste c'est incroyablement difficile
puisque ceci nécessite de comprendre tous les mécanismes
sociétaux qui permettent aux individus de vivre tel qu'ils vivent et d'accéder aux biens dont ils disposent ça passe par comprendre
l'origine et la production des biens comme des vestes en laine
l'origine et l'importance des ressources naturelles ou encore l'origine et la création de l'argent or les moyens de production d'une veste de laine
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles et le rôle de l'argent ainsi que toutes les notions qu'on a vu dans cette série comme les incentives
l'hooliganisme où le capital moral sont des notions très contre intuitive et souvent très mal comprise un
utilitariste qui ignorent cela sera nécessairement un très mauvais utilitariste pour un
utilitariste il s'agit dès lors d'un devoir moral que de comprendre autant que possible les sciences sociales pour ensuite déterminer
quelles actions permettront le bonheur du plus grand nombre il s'agit d'une condition nécessaire à l'utilitarisme
mai et ça le théoricien des jeux en moins adore il s'agit aussi d'une condition suffisante
autrement dit il s'agit d'une question scientifique que de déterminer que faire pour répondre au devoir moral
utilitariste bref
utilitariste aux une fin qui paraît légitime le bonheur général
et si la fin est légitime tous les moyens pour y arriver sont bons la fin justifie les moyens
Il me semble qu'un terrain jeu est forcément fasciné par l'utilitarisme et qu'il a même de bonnes chances de vouloir tendre vers cette philosophie morale
cependant l'utilitarisme a aussi ses limites et monsieur fille a notamment mise à l'épreuve
mon utilité risme et je dois bien dire que j'ai au moins quelques restes déontologique
d'ailleurs pour conclure j'aimerais insister sur trois difficultés majeures de l'utilitarisme
la première la notion d'équité on l'a déjà vu dans les vidéos 21 à 23
l'équité c'est pas une notion facile et pourtant on sent que c'est une notion crucial qui doit être rajoutées à l'utilitarisme
une approche pour un utilitarisme
équitable
est ce qu'on appelle le max mines fairness qui consiste à maximiser le bonheur du plus malheureux dans un article de ma thèse on a
étudié une alternative qui consiste à minimiser une pénalisation
exponentielle d'une forme de quantité de jalousie notamment dans un contexte
social
bon faut s'accrocher un petit peu mais j'invite quand même les plus motivés d'entre vous allez voir la seconde de difficulté et la manière de
traiter le futur par opposition au présent
une façon de faire consiste à considérer que le bonheur pendant 24 heures dans un an moins d'importance que le bonheur dans les 24 heures
qui viennent et ça en économie c'est typiquement modélisé par un facteur des secondes qui fait que l'importance du futur des croît exponentiellement
mais ce qui rend l'utilitarisme délicat c'est que ce facteur d ce conte
priori il est assez arbitraire et d'ailleurs ils varient clairement d'un individu à l'autre
enfin une troisième difficulté est que certains principes moraux que nous avons semble impossible à justifier à partir de fondement
utilitariste c'est le cas notamment de la protection de la biodiversité qui étrangement tient à coeur à nombre d'entre nous alors que bien souvent
détruire la biodiversité
pour planter des champs est souvent une bonne façon d'améliorer la production agricole et donc la qualité de vie des gens et donc
d'augmenter le bonheur du plus grand nombre et pour en savoir plus à ce sujet je recommande la superbe vidéo de dirt cheap et le
qui est aussi le premier épisode du podcast
axiome qu'on a lancé avec monsieur fille et je vous invite encore une fois allé voir la vidéo qu'on a fait sur sa chaîne où
il me met un peu mal à l'aise avec des expériences de pensée qui met à l'épreuve
l'utilitarisme
Justement comme vous l'aurez compris je l'espère show un énorme fan de ne se fier de tout ce qui fait notamment sur sa chaîne où
il ya énormément de vidéos qui sont vachement matheuse qui sont carrément des vidéos que j'aurais pu avoir fait sur scène soit roll
si j'avais eu le temps et l'intelligence j'avais notamment prévu de parler d' adam smith dans cette série et sur ses paroles soient démocratie mais
finalement comme il l'avait déjà fait et il avait tellement bien fait que ben je vous conseille vraiment d'aller voir et de voir ça comme
un complément à cette série sur la démocratie
mais il ya aussi des vidéos beaucoup plus matheuse est super intéressante notamment
souvent proche de la logique et je recommande là pour le coup fortement ses vidéos sur les lois de bise ou encore sa vidéo sur
le paradoxe du condamné que bruce d'y penser avait présenté mais des explications
additionnelles de monsieur prix sont vraiment vraiment génial et parle vraiment d'un problème au coeur des fondements de la logique donc je conseille vraiment vivement
vivement sa chaîne et je recommande également vivement le podcast qu'on a lancées ensemble
axiome l'idée du peu cassé c'est qu'on parle de façon beaucoup plus
informelle donc du coup c'est aussi plus long mais du coup je vous invite vraiment activement
écouter ça je sais pas pendant il transporte quelque chose comme ça
sachant qu'il ya pas grand chose à l'image c'est surtout le son qui compte
vous pouvez écouter ça en
voiture dans les transports que sais-je encore les harfangs n'a parlé de sélection de groupes et notamment le fait que la sélection naturelle a sélectionné
l'organisme politiques et notamment j'avais fini à la vidéo avec une citation de la marseillaise
dont le dernier vers 2 du refrain de la marseillaise qui car sang impur abreuve
nos sillons et vous avez été très nombreux à commenter et
affirmé que le sang impur de cette expression ne correspondait pas au sens et demi ce qui d'ailleurs intuitivement par un petit peu bizarre quand
vous y réfléchissez
mais surtout je vous recommande de l'excellente page wikipédia à ce sujet qui
discute très bien de la controverse autour de l'interprétation de ce dernier vers
notamment l'interprétation comme quoi ce sang impur ce sera le sang des citoyens même français du peuple français
c'est une théorie extrêmement récente qui semble complètement incompatible avec l'utilisation du mot sang impur à l'époque du coup sa tendance à être plutôt
rejetée par les historiens et honnêtement ça sent un petit peu ligue à nice mme patriotique que d'essayer de
réinterpréter le dernier verre de nîmes national français est du reste lorsque vous voyez les citations qui ont été relevés par
aymeric du caennaise vous voyez que la manière dont les gens parlaient pendant la révolution française a été vachement
hooligans patriotes mais à la limite tout ça on s'en fout complètement
ce qui compte en terme d'urbanisme politiques notamment de l'organisme politique qui sort de nous
lorsqu'on est marseillaise c'est plus le sens qu'on donne marseillaise aujourd'hui est ce que cette marseillaise
suggère pour nous et j'ai bien l'impression qu'avec une dernière phrase comme ça elle fait largement sortir le hooliganisme
patriotique franco-français en nous en particulier si j'ai mis un what the fuck à la fin de la vidéo précédente
s'est poursuivie nier la réaction de quelqu'un qui découvriraient l'hymne français et qu'il
interprèterait littéralement ça paraît quand même vachement violent
aeternam david chemla et etienne vers parent demande si le hooliganisme avait finalement une si mauvaise chose
ça permet la survie de nos groupes notamment or il faut faire gaffe la vidéo précédente était purement
descriptive c'est le but c'était de décrire la morale naturelle qui surgissait en nous après ça peut être bien ou mal
moi j'ai tendance à être assez
utilitarisme donc pour moi ce qui importe c'est le bonheur général
et du coup le giga nisme poétique et bien si et seulement si j'ai envie de dire il favorise le bonheur
globale en particulier si je prends un point de vue assez qui charisme sur la question de hesc d'hooliganisme petit que c'est bien ou mal
je veux vraiment envie d'insister sur le fait que ce soit bien ou mal n'est pas une règles déontologiques fondamentales
ce qui importe ce sont les conséquences de l'organisme politique et donc il est possible que dans beaucoup de cas ce soit très mal et
que dans beaucoup d'autres cas il ya eu kahnisme petit que soi très bien d'un point de vue
utilitariste en particulier c'est ça que je trouve très intéressant avec d'utilitarisme
ça évite de se poser des fausses questions du genre est ce que ça s'est bien mal se passer
qu'importe ce qui importe c'est quelles sont les conséquences de 6,1 et les conséquences de ci ou ça dépend de notamment du contexte
socio économique dans lequel on se pose ces questions donc il ya peut-être dû 2
ganis mon petit qui va dans ce sens mais j'ai quand même l'impression que la plupart du temps quand on est vraiment hooligans c'est à
dire lorsqu'on est prêt à défendre de façon irrationnelle et sans remettre en question ce que l'on pense
j'ai quand même vachement l'impression que ça empêche d'avoir une phase de réflexion qui pourrait par exemple mené à l'utilitarisme
notamment se demander quels sont les préférences des autres personnes
j'ai l'impression que lui ligue à nice mme est un frein qui a tendance à plutôt empêcher
une réflexion sur ce que l'autre pense du coup ça va à l'encontre j'ai l'impression avec un pire souvent de l'utilitarisme
bon après l'utilitarisme c'est une philosophie morale normative qui a beaucoup de qualités je pense
mais pour le coup c'est quelque chose de complètement débat table savoir si c'est vraiment bien ou mal
et de souhaiter le bonheur général et notamment il ya peut-être des trucs qui sont plus importants que le bonheur général
on parle notamment dans le podcast actionne avec
ses filles
bref j'aurais tendance à dire que la défense de nos groupes et pas forcément une mauvaise chose ça ça peut rapporter plus de bonheur que
de malheur mais l'hooliganisme qui ressort le fait de défendre irrationnellement
notre groupe est quelque chose de trop récurrent je trouve et
gagnerait
pour l'utilitarisme
réduire notre organisme poétique et à partir de meilleur fondement pour construire notre droite le titre harris mettant une alternative en tout cas un premier
jet qui je pense est intéressant et j'espère que j'aurai aimé cette vidéo qui vous allez penser aux fondements de votre philosophie morale
notamment c'est un effort à saintes à 100 de chercher à la décrire de la plus
simplement possible plutôt que chercher à avoir un avis moral sur des questions assez différente mais pas de façon
relier
quelqu'un il risquera fortement y avoir des inconsistances dans votre moral par ailleurs sachez que les semaines qui viennent les deux semaines qui viennent
il n'y aura pas d'épisode
de la série sur démocratie sur un central tout simplement parce que je pars en vacances et on reviendra après mes vacances
avec une vidéo sur le travail notamment le statut du travail quand il a évolué depuis
plusieurs siècles et notamment qu'est ce qu'il en est aujourd'hui
quelle est la bonne façon de penser le travail aujourd'hui et il y aura un autre invité à mecs j'adore également
qui viendra intervenir dans la vidéo à venir
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à liker à la commenter à la partager pense à vous abonner pour ne pas manquer les futurs
épisodes merci aux ti peur pour leurs dons et j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine fois l'inspiration le truc utilitariste sérieux
Guitariste
tarik a attiré sur le bouton qui n'a eu un sens aucun d'eux au curé sur les
tubes à dire avec le rapid match et pas la recherche en maths on a juste trouvé ce qu'il fallait de maths pour réussir à
faire marcher cette machine qui rend tout le monde heureux on attendait en plus ce serait triste non